[Music]
all right and what did he expect news
submitted by John Jame lien yep Joe moly
and Julian Jame lien hair dye that's my
country okay all right
a marathon runner who slapped the
reporter a reporter's but on live TV was
identified as a youth minister
oh I haven't made up my mind that he's a
bad guy you already made up your mind
you made up your mind I let it's just
off of that yeah he slapped a reporter
that on live TV
every time you say sports yeah I have a
different different yeah no no I call
[ __ ]
I played sports where we would slap each
other's ass cuz that's just what you do
when you're on a team right but he's not
on the same team is but when I'm not on
the team and I'm outside of being an
athlete well I'm not hitting people's
ass marathon she's a reporter have you
ever seen girls softball team I've seen
guys play dude cohort smacking all of
them coming out yeah but here's a big
noise for their plane this is a reporter
who's reporting on the marathon
who says over there yes so today we had
a record-breaking 5,000 I didn't picture
it was me and he just kept fine I
thought it was a guy reporter and he
just came up and he was doing a funny
thing that'd be okay it would be much
different okay I agree it definitely
would be different okay I'm not saying
it's okay but I just need more details I
think either way it goes the person that
the person who was smacked they can call
sexual harassment either way because
it's unwanted physical touch yeah either
way male or female but it is it
definitely comes off worse that it was a
guy that smacked a reporter but are you
but also keep in mind when you're
running a marathon the ridiculous outfit
you're wearing
you're the vulnerable one
and I mean if the reporters are in
regular clothes if you're wanting daisy
dukes and you have a giant number on
your chest that's your husband go home
to a knight now look at you now you're
questioning everything I said I do Bulls
to a different scenario let's say it was
another female marathon runner with him
and he smacked her but will we be more
like like they're both running whatever
and they both finished and he likes
Macker but it's a bad taste
it's still bad taste right either way
whether it was a co runner or for me I
don't think it's bad taste yeah cuz the
person is doing their jobs now you
interrupted their person from doing the
jobs trying to be funny
there's like two runners yes if you give
me Oh give us near you like it's not a
reporter the guidance of smacking the
girl runner I wouldn't jump to
conclusions good psycho they probably
know each other they probably have that
like relationship but a complete
stranger trying to do their job that's
not cool yeah that's this is that
[ __ ] oh I'm so funny I'm gonna do
something edgy right now like I'm trying
to get attention kind of [ __ ] so this is
Alex
she was the reporter and this is the
video it looks like Mario Lopez okay
that's video oh my goodness this will
give context because there's certain
kinds of smacks Maria Lopez that was
more than just a little Louis now he did
some more with that was it the guy at
the red shirt it was like oh yeah yeah
you know that was nice she was
completely disrespecting his defense huh
he's from behind yeah it could have been
a long hair dude yeah I can see that he
might not know it was I think it's one
of those things where everyone's like
doing the fun [ __ ] yeah this guy thinks
he's doing the same [ __ ] but it's like
bro you're you're like here everyone's
here I think there's no excuse I'm not
gonna make no skill I think I think
women have it hard enough going through
life just trying to be the best that
they can without being harassed by
guys she was doing her job yeah is no
excuse is not taking fun out of context
he's sexually assaulted her she did not
want there you could tell by her face
this he was like like now what does she
have custom I'm like what the [ __ ] is
your problem [ __ ] now she gets
potentially fired because someone like
interrupted her doing her job like I've
seen some of my closest friends and
family members hit glass ceilings
because they're women I've seen the
obstacles that they had to hop over
because they're women and I've seen them
objectified because they're women
so in this situation I'm just like
there's no excuse especially with him
being a youth pastor like that that just
adds insult to the energy grow you know
better you opposed to be preaching it's
every Sunday I think this guy should get
called out and humiliated because these
[ __ ] go through our life always
crossing the line and going work I'm
just [ __ ] around but it's like that's
not everybody was doing this thing like
whoo bunny ears right and you comes this
guy that that has to top everybody yeah
and I bet you he's a habitual habitual
[ __ ] they get away with it because
then there's like other people come in
and being like oh well they were just
kidding it's okay I don't know many
other people that would think that's
cool yeah like cuz I bet you this [ __ ]
does this to guys to everybody and he's
just never got his ass kicked I don't
think he does for guys I think he's not
I think he does it to people he feels
that he can overpower and won't say
anything ever met these [ __ ] though
that just how bitterly [ __ ] do this
over and over like to everybody and then
when they get their ass kicked they're
like oh man that's their fault
I've seen those type of people but I
also seen the people who hide behind the
cloth and their position like all my
youth has I would never do anything
intentionally to disrespect somebody so
like he could try to fall back on that
because I'm a youth pastor know you're
probably the worst [ __ ] con yeah we
all hear that story about how like he
fit the stereotype me worst kids well
you all hear that's it so like the fact
that you're you pastor use no warning or
no no safe haven for your behavior you
just did a [ __ ] up thing yeah we need
to own up for that [ __ ] that's a Boy
Scout leader so it's wrong
you're talking about because then
imagine him really lock him slapping for
someone to get to that point - they're
usually gonna be like stepping stones to
that so I'm sure there was like smaller
things that he's done it so far he's
like on my camera I'm whatever I'll do
this publicly now this happened before
that point that he gets to doing
something like that happy to tell you
before I've only been through their like
a passive let almost actually have whole
cars that are women only because there's
so much harassment I've heard that
because of how fully gets yeah I've seen
the guys like standing are close to them
on the trans like man space and it just
like it yeah right huh this is crazy
like a famous seats right over there
just been sitting all day so I just went
above my family's thought that spaces
what are you doing yeah they get I've
seen that but they were actually
supposed to come out with something here
I'm like that for solely for women only
to use because of all the I just saw
something yesterday like 2018 uber head
3,000 whoo all right all right live had
3,000 like sexual allegations can loves
and male drivers you know it's like oh
this is this is a problem and this type
of behavior yeah and it's not addressed
and it's not rectify and what it's not
like he should be publicly shamed when
that [ __ ] doesn't happen
people think it's good okay to continue
to do I call it the Trump effect it's
like when people come out normalized
hatred anything that is device divisive
like we come out and make that publicly
okay than other people love to hop on a
bear way and like it should be addressed
at all Mr P I used to drive for left and
I had a um it was a pool so I had a
young lady in the back and I pick up
another dude and that dude like kept
like talking about her and like oh
you're lucky man he have like this you
know hot young lady in the back and I
was like what do you do it right now
you're makin comfortable you've added
like texture after a yeah kick them out
can you do know about kicking a cocky I
was knew at that point and I was like I
don't wanna like loses money whatever
like that I just took me to spy but it
was just like don't make her
uncomfortable in like my own car you
know that kind of situation and then
also like you were saying like being
able to call that out don't just like
sit around just like listen up dudes
have some no [ __ ] idea he said so
normal
like the normal thing for him to just
like to utter like it was just like yeah
yeah like no that's not how you taught
me things he's a [ __ ] dude um I guess
she's in the car with two dudes in the
front like he's gonna be a couple
already upset so he was sit at the front
he's in the front because he was a pool
I mean he could he got in the back with
her which mean more creepy but he's not
in the front of me but even so like you
know when she's in the back it's dark
you know it was night at that point like
don't that's a bad situation to start if
I can like add feeling that until I'm is
don't make it weird
yeah and I don't want your weirdness to
travel over to me that's exactly [ __ ]
up my tips you know I'm sorry that dude
came in like that and like I know you
probably do with that like don't you're
like I know you probably do things
you're so beautiful
fired I'll be part of that 3,000 3,000
change me that in there so anyways that
reporter she ended up saying that he
hurts her so she said quote he hurt me
both physically and emotionally so she
was just like really disgusted that this
man cuz at that time they didn't know
who he was yet but people could see it
on her face
exactly so she ended up tweeting this to
the man who smacked my butt on live TV
this morning you violated objectified
and embarrass me no woman should ever
have to put up with this at work or
anywhere do better so then that's when
the viewers started looking for this
nice was wearing his like his marathon
number and [ __ ]
that's how they were able to determine
who he is and imagine being on church on
Sunday and everyone knows mission a
servant they should serve him his
[ __ ] papers at church
yeah you've Minister here's Tommy uh he
looks like that kind of [ __ ] - he's
from Georgia Southern accent that's as
exactly that completely makes sense
all these [ __ ] man I can't wait till
the day that Georgia Florida got banned
from racing mm-hmm his lawyer came out
with the statement saying uh he said
these dudes he said uh so he said he's a
loving husband and father who was very
active in his community and local church
and he was insisting that he is working
with those involved to correct the
situation
well we regret the situation miss turkey
needs to get [ __ ] served mr. Calloway
did not act with any criminal intention
no one ever what did I tell they get
caught what does it mean to rob a house
until I got caught yeah what does it do
like that have to do for like I guess SS
society or like you know anybody who's
following the story to make us feel like
yeah I feel like you're actually taking
the steps to write filiation man public
humiliation you think I think or maybe
from a girl's point of view because like
you guys deal with this all the time so
what do you guys feel like okay justice
was served to do with like this is set
an example the public humiliation for me
would be really good because now
everyone that he comes in contact with
now they know what his history is and
they're like okay now we can act
accordingly
so public humiliation in the sense of
him coming out speaking on what he did
while I was wrong and apologizing or
like public humiliation somebody coming
and stuffing his dick I like that what
her too
and he still he still has to do the
apology not even a dick balls two thumps
on the balls not like that because
that's it we'll take a man down yeah
that's it a drop an elephant you can't
get elephant in the balls that's how you
save a life
yeah guarantee allistic Lee that
wouldn't really happen so in the
realistic sense of things
spray paint his face I think what would
make me feel better I paint his eyelids
noe is like having his ass Colt go on
live television and like national
television and apologize to my face and
also he's no longer to be able to be a
youth pastor or a Boy Scout leader cuz
imagine what the [ __ ] is teaching a boy
that's true we have to run a marathon
backwards that's good I think he should
have to renounce his his stance on his
position with the Boy Scouts and the
church because like you like to say like
that type of behavior like racism is it
I'm not born with it you taught it
taught it yeah no telling what he's
teaching these kids on is fine if she
likes you gonna hit her back like that
Cypress eat like that's all thinking
wrote is hella outdated so I agree with
that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]